see fit
show them how we spilled blood
we escaped to where the surface
oh yeah it was about time yeah really
thank you for the walking around I'm not
gonna say who super handsome people are
walking around with shields made out of
stuff from the Kingdom of Wakanda
vibranium you know what if they're
walking around with that stuff and a
source of the vibranium ought to be
there hey everybody so I've been getting
a lot of requests for an agents of
shield update video plus we're getting
ready for the hundredth episode in Jeff
low
Clark Gregg everyone's been teasing that
it's gonna be a big event because you
may have guessed that because it's a
Friday night show their hundredth
episode is going to air the Friday that
Black Panther is released in theaters so
typically they always have some sort of
movie tie-in so there's a number of like
really big events that they've been
teasing they're gonna pay off in that
hundredth episode so I'll explain a
little bit about what's going on this
season what's probably going to end up
happening in the hundredth episode there
are a couple things that we know are
going to happen because of the way
they've been producing the episodes and
the things the cast members have been
saying what'll probably happen later
this season there are 22 episodes total
and whether or not we're gonna find out
if it's gonna get renewed for season 6
or it's gonna get cancelled like what's
going on with that because if you're not
a big TV person they're having a lot of
big TV panels for the Television Critics
Association they announced a lot of
cancellations and renewals so we might
find out about that so they're just a
crap ton of Marvel TV stuff that's going
on not just from shield from all the
other stuff too so be sure to subscribe
if you're just finding me for the first
time I'll do a new Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway at the end of this - this promo
for next week's episode is for episode 7
they're still dealing with the new Kree
billons the band has largely gotten back
together but we just learned about
Cassius's family his brother is way
worse with a way larger space fleet and
their father is like this giant Creed
general we don't know if he's a
character from the comics because this
is set 90 years in the future so I think
they have a little more freedom with the
comic book characters that they do
because this isn't happening right in
present-day with all this infinity war
stuff but they've been hyping up this
crazy father they just
wharfs anything that we've been seeing
so far so it sounds like they'll pay
that off as we head into the hundredth
episode they're still in the future
timeline but Jeff lobe teased for the
hundredth episode that there'll be a
number of big events happening in the
team has to get back home
so here's what we get in 200th episode
predictions they're real like four or
five big events that they need to pay
off that they've been teasing so one is
the destruction of the earth we'll
probably learn more about what this
crazy prophecy is they keep thinking
that Daisy is destined to quake the
earth apart and become the quake
character like her name is Daisy but in
the secret warriors comics her name is
quake the TV shows been using that name
as a villain would so it's almost like
the quake
Daisy character of the TV show is this
supposed @ villain that we don't know
anything about like why would she quake
the earth apart there's a lot of
theories about that it gets into crazy
dimension-hopping stuff there's the nuke
Riva lands like the crazy space general
that we just learned about who's the
father of these two characters there's
the team getting back to present-day
there's the Fitzsimmons wedding like
they just proposed to each other so they
have to pay that off at some point this
season then we have dove Cameron the
spider-gwen
of the Marvel Universe who's coming in
what looks like the eleventh episode in
the twelfth episode is supposed to be
their 100th episode so it sounds like
they find her in the future and bring
her back to the past so you're all
asking what does that have to do with
Black Panther if this is dropping the
same night as Black Panther what are
they gonna do some special promotion is
there gonna be some special crossover
they haven't said anything about that
and we don't know if Coulson is aware of
the existence of Wakanda they though is
play it fast and loose with who knows
what pieces of information because we
remember way back during Avengers age of
Ultron you have a collection of some of
the smartest people in the Marvel
Universe Tony Stark Bruce Banner that
say Wakanda for the first time like they
don't know how to pronounce it I know
that guy back in the day he operates off
the African coast black market arms
there are conventions right meet people
I didn't tell him anything he was
talking about finding something new a
game-changer it was all very he had this
tattoo or not think he had it those are
tattoos this is a brand oh yeah it's a
word in an African dialect meaning thief
in a much less friendly way
what dialect what Kannada what what what
what condom but this guy got out of
Wakanda or some of their trade goods I
thought your father said he got the last
of it I don't follow what comes out of
Wakanda the strongest metal on earth but
they just sounds like part of the height
that they're building for the reveal
like the world learning that it exists
and it's way more advanced than you ever
would have imagined like this promised
city of gold
Eldorado have you ever heard of it so I
think what'll happen is is they'll find
some way to include Easter eggs for
stuff that's happening during Black
Panther but I don't know that we're
gonna see any characters from that movie
show up on agents of shield in the
hundredth episode because like I said
there's already like those five big
things that they have to pay off
primarily the team getting back to
present-day
and finding out the truth of the earth
being quaked apart like there's got to
be some bigger villain than Daisy the
destroyer of worlds
unless they really are doing multiverse
and they've gone to a different
dimension where a different version of
Daisy really is evil and quakes the
earth apart and she becomes the villain
of the back half of the season that
would actually be pretty interesting if
you think that Chloe Bennet as an
actress could pull that off like you
have to be pretty compelling and people
weren't so sure about Grant Gustin
playing the villain and the hero of the
flash season 3 he did an okay job there
were some pretty good scenes but at
times it just felt like an emo version
of Barry so it could be hit or miss when
you have your younger actors playing the
big villains on the series while they're
also playing their normal hero
characters there's still a lot of
questions about who dove Cameron is
playing on the show if they find her in
the future and they've been trafficking
in Inhumans she might be one of those
Inhumans that was sold off so she could
have special powers but I don't think
that she's gonna be spider-gwen they
could make a lot of jokes about that but
I'm also expecting Ghost Rider to come
back sometime before the end of the
series because it is very possible that
this is the final season of agents of
shield there have been a couple things
behind the scenes that they've been
doing like things that they would
normally put off to the final season
like we won't have another chance to do
it so we better do it now kind of stuff
the Fitzsimmons wedding Clark Gregg
directing an episode this like really
big celebratory things that you would
only do if you thought your show wasn't
going to continue but typically what
happens with that is is you don't hear
cancellation or renewable till a show is
at least half way done through airing
episodes but they have the tcas this
weekend so if they do have any
announcements about what the future of
shield is going to be if we're gonna get
a season six I'll be sure to do a video
about it but anything to they have not
revealed whether or not
Inhumans has formally been cancelled or
renewed now I think me nah made a joke
about it possibly being canceled so I
really do think that they've cancelled
that from behind the scenes and they're
just waiting to announce that well let
me know in the comments what do you
think they're gonna do in the back half
of the season if this really is going to
be shield's final season
I know there are flashbacks in Avengers
4 like there's some sort of weird
time-travel stuff that's going on we'll
talk about that when we get closer to
infinity war because I don't think it
has anything to do with bringing Coulson
back from the dead but there is a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber just share the video using
the YouTube tools on the watch page
there I'll name a new winner when I post
new Marvel there is a new black panther
trailer that's supposed to drop Monday
night so obviously I'll do a video for
that so just leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below
but click here to learn all about Thanos
true name just being revealed in his
mission during infinity war and Avengers
4 and click here for more black panther
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]